you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am on leeches
org and playing a four to blitz game
against somebody once more in Zen mode
all right let's try Scotch opening
before check I believe a good replying
if I play Bishop d2 I believe Queen h4
is a mover Queen e7 actually
I'm gonna say let's just go with c3 but
unsure what to do and go elsewhere with
this night okay I was threatening to
take and then take on c5 I'm gonna say
let's put this knight here right now
you know I guess so I've looked at this
before I believe and I think the move is
Bishop to c4 not a hundred percent on
that now I'm gonna go a different spot
I'm gonna go to d3 overprotect e4 and
maybe prepare to take and push let's see
how my my center comes under fire here
we go so I'm gonna give this a go I'm
gonna take on c6 I am giving them the a
file with this sequence but we're gonna
try to do something with this pawn on e5
so I'm not normally a big fan of this
but I'm trying to I guess argue that my
pawn on e5 can be disruptive we'll see
okay I thought Knight g4 mm-hmm Queen h5
rook e1 I'm gonna start with this I was
tempted to do this but I think Knight c5
bishop back in Bishop g4 I want to avoid
the pin so of the two ways to defend he
five I want to sidestep Bishop g4 so
tactical shots on h7 Queen h5 come to
mind would they do something aggressive
Queenie Queen g5 Queen h5 I don't know
we'll see
what is black considering maybe
challenging my pond maybe hitting it
again queen g5 here in that I could
sneak in a flight square and prevent a
potential pin at least they're thinking
here I really blitzed out those first
handful moves hmm Brooke lift is not yet
there maybe in some position when my
queen goes elsewhere
there's backup here possibly certainly
an aggressive approach yes for sure
Queen would really be hitting in all
directions from d4 feel like I'm still
pressure I want to get one more moving
hmm maybe I have to tolerate the pin I
like that my bishop boxes out the night
what am i doing reply to d4 d4 Knight
here D 3 oh I think I need to take takes
Queen d4 and then have to give up a beat
the the beep on I don't know
actually ahead on the clock
this is the move that concerns me most I
think the Queen is so strong if on d4
hmm I wouldn't mind seeing a quieter
move okay yeah this is I'm not entirely
quiet and certainly uh challenging a
strong pawn um I have at least a
perpetual maybe more can I be aggressive
here Queen h5 here sacrifice check check
and then a rook lifts hmm
Queen h4
here takes takes takes with check I have
a perpetual I don't have this square but
I could give check King g8 and then here
can I be assured of getting to this
square I think I can and then the king
is running for his life
I'm not a hundred percent sure of how
it's going to work out but we're going
to give it a go this does week in the
light squares move upon from a light
square and you're weakening it at least
some light squares so here I could sneak
in
see I'm threatening mate one two three
22 I believe this was the most testing
d4 alrighty let's see what's what's why
considering maybe f5 if f5 my pawn lives
hmm maybe maybe f5 with the idea of
Knight e4 you know this pawn would be
passed but there is a good piece around
to blockade the knight is normally the
ideal piece ok we're gonna go in for it
and do I insert the check now or do I go
here first actually I think I like the
idea of maybe here and then here yeah I
don't have to do that I could go to
Queen Queen h6 on my next move
let me just consider uh considering
switching the move order
oh yeah even maybe I maybe I want to go
here control this square I can't be
prevented from going here yeah if I go
here here and then here maybe there's
Bishop here here followed by f5 I want
to keep control over this for a moment
I think rookie 3 immediately the king is
stuck in there yeah let's go here
immediately so I believe I'm threatening
main whew check here check check me the
night is too far away from blocking
Paquette take here it's not a reliable
defender of g3 so how are they pairing
my mate threat here runs into main one
they're under 40 clean here at minimum I
have check and then takes with the
discovered attack against the Queen also
ok yeah check ok I think I'm winning the
Queen at least shack block I get the
rook check here check here here I'm
picking up the Queen so I think this is
working out rooks are not yet connected
under 20 and have to look back the d4
move scary see who were playing against
ok this one is over aha
not my first time playing against juicy
ketchup was the opponent ok before I
forget let me resize the board I did a
little bit bigger there GG juicy ketchup
have a look at this one yeah
note
you
right into the analysis on this one let
me request a computer analysis
and I believe this there's some Queen
move yeah I've played Bishop d2 before
and in reply to this capture I'm really
happy I develop a piece I still maintain
the c3 square for my knight
and the strong pawn on e4
concern you know after having some
experience with this line is queenie
seventies
a bit annoying you know if I'm taking
here Queen takes b4 is hitting just way
too much and there's even Queen takes e4
stuff
apparently night b5 d5 this is getting
really sharp Queen takes e4 Bishop e2 I
guess a bit inconvenient for a black to
defend c7 but apparently d5 yeah defense
like this okay yeah anyhow worth noting
it may initially well my first
experience with this I played Bishop d2
thinking oh you take my knight I go here
I'm happy and the other sequence as
mentioned I'd be happy there as well but
Queen e7 is a strong reply to Bishop d2
so I went with c3 and then suggests just
take the knight right away it should be
three okay
nothing nothing great this is the graph
inaccuracies mistakes and blunders for
each okay
so let's have a look at this d4 move
that concerned me okay knight c6 this is
where things are definitely heating up
takes takes does not want to take on b6
uh-huh yeah I could I guess I could hold
off it's suggesting rook e1 this is
purposeful defend the bishop don't give
black the file right away eventually I
went here in the game but I'm not you
know I'm not straightening out there
Queen side structure by taking on b6 so
Ricky one is an improvement for me I
capture ePHI v' 97 f4 wants to go with
I wanted to play without that I guess I
could have I guess I could have gone
with it then I would feel a bit more
comfortable allowing a pin you know if
um just make a dummy move if I go here I
really don't mind this pin because my
queen could go somewhere else in my rook
is now defending now that the pawn is on
f4 instead of f2 yeah I guess I should
have considered more the f4 move
especially in a position type where
black doesn't have a dark square bishop
there's still the queen that could hurt
me along the diagonal but there's no
dark square bishop so maybe I could see
this more as a positive than a negative
in these position types ones absent the
dark square bishop
anyhow rookie one night c5 Bishop c2 and
it does want to play D 496 let's have a
look at d4 I thought I thought I was
gonna end up taking his knight Knight
here this this bothered me even just
ruining my structure bothered me takes
takes what would I do here look at the
recommendation I I don't know these
aren't happy moves to play Queen c1 yeah
well this is the one that bugged me and
it appears to be pretty strong d 4o k f6
it doesn't want to play queen h5 queen
h5 a4 and I guess g6
oh the other sacrifices working in the
end it's not just it is there it's not
just something flashy apparently best is
to shut things down
give me the past pawn but as mentioned
in the game there are two good pieces I
would say that
are well positioned on e6 the Niner
bishop
what would I do from here yeah I was
leaning towards getting the night their
night here and I think right around this
point I'd want to move my night again
and give this night a boot but I guess
there's some slower approach have this
guy defend the any pond and then free
this guy up to centralise and we go from
here roughly equal position okay well
and this one g6 was played and I guess
you know there are more than
there's more than one way to do it Queen
age six or brookie three is working my
concern with this and then rookie three
was Bishop g4 still winning now yeah I
could come back over and pick up pick up
the bishop
okay so g6 was just not working
and yeah I believe so now cuz this I get
the rook and what else King here I'm
getting the Queen at minimum rook g7
yeah I get the Queen and he's completely
winning okay well a shorter game did Zen
mode yet again and well as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away
that's all for now take care bye
you